i have one guy that i'm obsessed with
these days i want to get your thoughts
on this guy patty the baddie pimplet
what are your thoughts on this guy yeah
i met him briefly in in in england in
manchester too yeah he's very
charismatic yeah um
he's good he's a he to be a successful
to be successful in this business of
fighting
you need to be skilled but
more than that you need to be
charismatic and in order to be
charismatic a lot of guys feel
that they need to trash talk to to
imitate conor mcgregor but you don't
have to do that i sold a lot of
pay-per-view because i was just
authentic to who i am and i think
paddy the baddie is he's very authentic
yeah i think he's a very charismatic guy
he's got a weird style
i really enjoy watching him fight and i
think he's going to be a he's still a
star but he's going to be even more of a
of a big draw you know what i mean i
think the sky is the limit and i think
he is being authentic i don't think it's
an act no it's not an act but there is
guys that it you could clearly see it's
an act it's unfortunate because they
shoot themselves in their foot when they
do that you know yeah
yeah because it doesn't work for them it
doesn't work for them and to be it's got
to be natural you need to be like you
are like like and sometimes it's not
necessarily malicious in a malicious way
you you we all do this
for the best of our own interests and
some guys they will do this because they
know that's the best
the best way they can help themselves to
achieve what they want to achieve you
know what i mean it's not i don't see it
necessarily in a malicious way even like
like you see like sometimes conor
mcgregor will say stuff that are very
edgy i mean
for me it's
no it's it's could become personal
because he will attack your personal
life but it's
it's it's it's business in that way you
know what i mean so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]